my daughter was born Sarah I remember I
was scoring in the studio in London and
at eleven o'clock at night I got this
call from the hospital saying come down
your daughter's about to be your child
is about to be born did notice a dose of
the time but I then rushed off to the
hospital spent a few hours and when she
was safely delivered went back to the
studio and wrote the baby Lance try the
theme for which aria I have a particular
fondness for this sort of this piece of
music because it has significance for me
you know just bears my my eldest
daughter all this stuff is not one
digital thing in this there's nothing
optical as far as the creatures go the
opticals which were old-time digital's
we're really for the background just to
get more Sun a son or something but the
actual creatures were all real and it
was a [ __ ] I did two of the characters
I did audra and I did Skeksis and but I
didn't do the voices because my voices
were too well-known I'll tell you one
thing there's about ten Skeksis 12
Skeksis I don't even know I've forgotten
anyway but you know what was funny is
that we did every time we got the
Skeksis on I had a Skeksis on Jim had
and we were directing and the other guys
we all had television monitors inside
and we had Mike so we could then Jim and
I could talk to each other and talk to
the guys but what was funny was every
time we did take those two people to
Skeksis for instance once the take is
over you collapse and somebody comes
from the side a helper and takes the
weight and somebody else comes with a
hair dryer and bulls all the
perspiration away and there's about if
there's ten Skeksis 12 i think is 10 ok
just 10 sec Exies so whenever we said
cut 20 people rushed on the stage to
take care of all the Skeksis and the
blow drying everything so is a huge
thing